[Music]
there we go could they still hear me
though when i said all that
all right so all that stuff i just said
uh something something something uh
nakamura
and um anyway
these two games that aronian played
uh
kind of jumped out to me because
they were both queen's gambit accepted
and this is like my favorite opening of
all time it's such an underrated opening
and um you know everybody's looking at
nimzo indian kings indian groomfeld all
these crazy lines and the queen's gonna
be accepted to me it's like one of the
easiest openings that you can play as
black but also if you're looking to put
a little
a little bit of a dynamic spin on it
there are plenty of options there
for black as well and i think this is
perhaps the most entertaining of them
right so after d take c4 we get our
basic queens gambit accepted position
and one of the things i like about the
queen's gambit accepted it's just that
it's so practical
right as opposed to those lines where
you you have to memorize like 20
different variations
and then within those variations there's
all these sidelines and it's enough to
drive you crazy like to me openings like
the groomfeld seem almost unplayable
unless you have an unlimited amount of
time
and on top of that a team of like 10
super gm's that are feeding you lines
constantly
i don't think you can get away with this
these kinds of openings
at least at a high level
so me being kind of
lazy i guess you could say but also
human
i look for
openings that i can actually digest
right and the queen's gambit accepted
already kind of
narrows down
white's
critical options by that i mean just
ways in which white can create serious
problems
because here
historically white's main moves have
been e4
knight f3 and recently e3 has become
quite popular
but by far the most challenging move or
at least the most aggressive option for
white has been the move e4
already i mean if you want to punish the
queen's gambit accepted by playing e4 i
mean this is an ambitious move right
white's saying oh okay thanks for the
center
and now i'll just get my pawn back and
everything
is going to be great
well
not so fast right because
black has a lot of options even the old
school option e5 i think is still very
interesting
after e5
white needs to know what he's doing
because if you just start taking every
pawn that crosses your path
you're going to start running into some
trouble for example after
queen takes d1 king takes the one
knight c6
black is very likely going to play
bishop e6 and castle queenside next and
and this king is um
he's not
very well placed on d1 to say the least
so usually white goes something like
knight f3 and after pawn takes bishop
takes
knight c6 this is one of the i'd say
maybe after castles
one of the key starting positions of the
e4 variation i've always thought the the
move bishop e6 was interesting um it
leads to some very messy positions which
you know
it's certainly something that
i'm not against on principle but it
really does hold up so one of the key
ideas is that if you take this pawn and
you try to
recover your pawn
black's just going to say
that's okay i'm not really interested in
having an extra pawn
what i am interested in
is
finishing my development and creating
some kind of imbalance here so so
usually black's going to follow up with
moves like bishop d6
castles and e5
and black's going to pin all of his
hopes on this d4 pawn
so i think that position is fine for
black
white has some other interesting options
with bishop b5 i think this is probably
the most testing move but i think black
is um
is holding his own not without effort
but
nonetheless i think black is okay a move
that i played for many years was
actually knight c6
which is a very provocative move
because
i know has anybody ever seen the
alekhine variation
against e4
um
it's after e4 knight f6
ever come across this
no bobby fisher actually played this
with black
in his match against boris spassky in
1972 and he won a nice game you know
this is an opening
that was considered almost unplayable
and
a lot of strong players have tried it
i actually tried it one time and once
was enough i got absolutely destroyed
but it's a provocative move because what
you're trying to do is provoke an over
expansion
by white right
this could backfire and it could just be
like an absolutely steamrolling attack
but you know after something like d4 d6
well white has knight f3 but the most
aggressive way that white can play is
the four pawns attack
and you know
there's certainly
an argument to be made in favor of black
you know black can start chipping away
at the center with moves like c5 or
knight c6
so
the idea of knight c6 in the
qga
that's queen's gamut accepted for the
layman
is
to do something very similar to provoke
these pawns to move forward so that then
we can start chipping away at them for
example
if you
if you sort of go the four pawns attack
approach
you're going to run into some trouble
pretty quickly for example
knight d3 bishop takes pawn takes queen
takes and already black is is going to
start playing moves like you know c6 e6
knight f6 and your pawn is doomed
now recently i think white has created
some some pretty interesting problems
against knight c6
so
you know i'm probably looking more
towards e5 but there's one line it's the
craziest line that black can play
against e4 it's also the most ambitious
and that is the move
b5
now after b5 black is saying you know
what i really i've grown quite attached
to my pawn on c4
and i'm not quite ready to to give it up
yet
normally
this is considered almost suicidal to do
like any any kind of queen pawn opening
where you take the pawn on c4 and you
try to keep it cling to it at all cost
it's going to spell disaster for example
here
after the move uh
knight c3
oh well you could start with a4 actually
what happened in the game
c6 pawn takes pawn takes and knight c3
you already have some trouble holding on
to your extra pawn if if you go
uh
b4 i think after
let's see
i think after simply queen a4 right i'm
picking up this pawn
so that's out of the question and after
a6 which is the move that i
i used to think was kind of like the
only way of handling this
white has knight takes b5
and it seems like oh now this is
devastating i lost one pawn i'm going to
lose the next
but
after pawn takes black can sack the
exchange
and then
uh
it's kind of funny
you don't even need to take this pawn on
e4 in fact
uh
one of the best lines for black
is e6
and if you say oh well you missed your
chance right then black starts
really coming at you with everything
he's got i think the best move here
after pawn takes was something like 97
and after pawn takes knight f5 so it's
just insane
right um black is threatening queen h4
there's bishop b4 ideas there's knight
takes d4 ideas so
this is a really really interesting
line for black
white has found some ways
some very computer-ish ways
of
attempting to refute this i think like
rook a2 there were some important
subtleties there
so when nakamura played this and
actually nakamura was not the first to
play this aronian got
this position twice in the grand prix
the first time he got it was against
lanier dominguez so i wanted to start
with that game
um
here
queen b6
totally new move right at least for me i
mean i'm sure that it hasn't been played
several times
do we have let's see yeah
let's see helmet it hasn't been played
that many times actually only eight
games
four games featuring knight d5 and
another four featuring b3
now
b3
is the first move that i would be
terrified of
right because
if i play the obvious move c takes b3
white's gonna take my pawn on b5 with
check and then take my pawn on b3 and
everything just starts falling apart
you know i'm not really down any
material per se but i haven't developed
any pieces and my my queen side's wide
open
so
what are some
ideas that black could play here i mean
what could black have up his sleeve to
avoid just total collapse
by the way this is a very difficult
position
at least uh maybe some
options right they don't have to be good
moves but it's just somewhere that we
can use as a starting point
what was that b4 okay yeah b4 could be a
move
right now at least there's no queen a4
check or anything like that
but then
maybe white's going to play knight d5
hitting our queen and then playing
bishop takes c4 right so we lose our
pawn and we don't really address the
underlying problem in black's position
which is that you haven't developed a
single piece besides your queen
so b4
good place to start doesn't really solve
our problems
in the chat
they're mentioning
a very interesting move
pawn to e6 so my follow-up question
would be like okay what happens if white
just takes the pawn
and again let's try to
remember
what problem black is trying to solve
like when you when you have extra
material
one of the worst things that you can do
is just
desperately cling to it right
to make your entire game
revolve around the fact that you have
extra material that should never be the
reason why you like your position you
should always be able to say something
good about your position that goes
beyond the material itself like you have
active pieces safer king better pawn
structure something right
material advantage should be a means to
an end not the end itself
and when you have that extra material i
feel it's a useful
attitude
to see that material as a bargaining
chip that it gives you bargaining power
that you can give it back in order to
get something in return
and that's exactly what black is doing
here right black is giving back a pawn
but now black
is going to start bringing his pieces
out with several
annoying threats right first bishop
before
attacking the knight pinning the knight
and if you play something like knight g2
right defending the knight on c3 then i
can go b take c4
and
it's true these pawns they're not the
prettiest pawns i've ever seen
but again we're not that concerned about
keeping the c4 pawn although it's not
going to be easy to recover it
for white
but rather
we want to play moves like
knight f6 castles rook d8 putting
pressure on d4 knight c6 putting
pressure on d4 if need be we can play a5
bishop b7 putting pressure on e4 maybe
bishop a6 if we need to defend the pawn
on c4
so all of a sudden
all of these avenues start opening up
for black's pieces and we get a clear
view
of what we need to do
so
knight g2
is not even
a very good move for white i think
white's probably already on the
defensive there
so
black is forcing white to play some
thoughtful moves right they're it's very
difficult for both white and black to
just go on autopilot and just make
random moves and that's one of the
reasons why
it's so interesting to consider this
variation because if you're familiar
with it you can create a lot of
practical problems for your opponent the
best move here is bishop d2
which looks kind of
scary because now your d4 pawn
is hanging right
but what happens if black goes queen
takes d4
yeah right just yeah just take
take on b5
and if bishop well i don't know if
bishop takes d2
careful right because if
if queen takes d2 then your rook is
hanging on a1 with check
so
so what's the deal here
yeah
nightwear uh e2 why e2 because we're
defending our other knight and we're
also pushing on the queen yeah so maybe
92
this could work but what if i
take this pawn here
which i'm not saying this is necessarily
great
but i think that
you get a much
better flow to your position if you play
knight f3 right without blocking your
bishop because now the queen is going to
have to move and here i can definitely
play a move like knight takes b5 and
after bishop takes queen takes
i haven't really done what i wanted to
do as black right it wasn't about
winning more pawns it was about
finishing my development and putting
pressure on white's position and really
the the opposite has happened right
white got a bunch of pieces out and
i'm not even up upon or anything not
that that would you know justify but
it's not clear what i've gained from
this
so
the point is not to
to take on d4 at least not right away
and
yeah i think that
uh let's see
right after
b takes c4 was this played already so
bishop b4 bishop d2 b takes e4 bishop
takes c4 yeah it was played four times
some pretty strong players too
and um and here
97 right so so black is going to
continue in this vein right of just
castling going rook d8 knight c6 a5 all
the typical moves that black wants to
play and i think black is doing quite
okay here and actually check this out if
you don't believe me you know the engine
says that for all this craziness we're
still
within a pretty safe margin in terms of
you know
uh the evaluation
so aronian decides to go
for a much more aggressive
uh
idea plays the move knight d5
right attacking our queen
it seems like our queen b6 move was just
an invitation
for it to get attacked by a knight and
not only that the queen has to retreat
to a kind of uncomfortable square which
is the b7 square you know we would have
thought that that square was meant for
the bishop
but at the same time
if bla if white doesn't have anything
tangible soon we're going to play e6 and
then we're going to go knight f6 bishop
b4 castles rook d8 knight c6 and all
that good stuff
so
what could white's
follow-up
be
but you want to be very careful when you
make an incursion
into your opponent's side of the board
with your pieces because you should
immediately assume that the first chance
your opponent gets he's going to start
firing away at your pieces and trying to
push you back
so
what is white going to do here
any ideas
and usually when
when you're behind enemy lines
you have to base your play on sort of
very concrete approach right it's not
like you can just comfortably maneuver
on your opponent's side of the board the
same way that you would on your own side
of the board right because that's what
the space advantage is for when you move
your pawns forward that usually means
that you have
these safe squares right that your pawns
create a sort of safe perimeter for your
pieces so when you move beyond that
perimeter
you're
you're in the red zone right there's
there's all sorts of ways that your
opponent can uh
can start creating threats on your
pieces so yes here in the chat they're
mentioning the move bishop f4 very
natural move
it develops the bishop and creates this
devastating threat
of knight c7 so the first thought would
be well i'll just stop knight c7 right
with with the knight a6 but what what
happens here this is a pretty
straightforward tactic
yeah just rook takes a6 and the game is
over
so
so what's going on here uh did lanier
dominguez who was the first one to play
this
and nakamura both miss
bishop f4 did nagamura repeat the same
line and fall for the same trap of
course not right
so what could the idea be and again
whenever you're dealing with a highly
complex position
you always want to go back to basics you
always want to go back to the core idea
the the reason why you're playing this
and remember that black is playing this
variation to develop his pieces quickly
he's using material as a bargaining chip
well if e6
knight c7 check
right now when you move the king you're
gonna lose your rook i mean maybe you
could take here but i don't know i think
i could
what could i do bishop e2 knight e2
bishop e3
i got to be a little bit careful with
this check right
um
but i think i could go 92 and against
check i could go bishop d2
and that looks
pretty okay
so in the chat we have an interesting
suggestion here
e5
same idea as e6 right we want to clear
the diagonal for the bishop but we want
to do it
uh
we want in an expedited way right
because now you can't really play knight
c7 because of queen takes knight the
pawn's interfering
with the bishop so white has to take the
pawn
and now what
in the chat they were saying bishop b4
that would be very unfortunate because
the knight hasn't committed to c7 yet so
i can just take your bishop
this is really where the game gets
trippy
yes
right
we keep developing
knight d7
now
this looks ridiculous because it does it
doesn't stop
the check
in fact after king d8
knight takes a8
what's uh what's going to happen here
what's black's big idea
queen to
e4 now
and if i do something like bishop
e2 uh
so before we
i think a useful
tool to make sure that your calculation
is as accurate as possible
is to sketch out the moves that you want
to play right before you before you
choose one and run with it you want to
lay out your options right so
what are the moves that you would like
to see
for black
okay i mean you mentioned this one right
this is one
but this can't be the only move that we
want to play
use knight to capture bishop okay
also bishop v4 yeah
sure maybe even if we can we want to
bring a rook into the game right so this
is more or less the sketch of what we
want and it's important
to draw this sketch before you
you commit yourself
to even calculating a variation let
alone playing one right because
this is what's going to feed
your your brain right so your brain is
going to say okay this is where i want
all my pieces to go and then you're
going to draw from that to put together
variations now if you only look at one
move
right your brain is just going to that's
all the raw materials your brain is
going to have so it's not going to come
up with a lot of original ideas if it
has
such constraints on it
so
our job is let's say
in the first part to sketch out our
options and in the second part
we need to figure out the order in which
we need to play these pieces of the
puzzle right so so queen takes e4 is
definitely an option but now
the move bishop b4
can definitely be an option first of all
we're developing a piece with tempo with
check
secondly there's not a really good way
to block the check and after king e2
queen takes e4 is checkmate
right so
this is an easy tactic to miss if you're
just
you know if you just have this tunnel
vision where you all you see is
capturing pieces like oh the pawn e4 is
hanging the knight on a8 is hanging i
have to take one of these pieces
then
all of a sudden you start missing things
so
so this is an important idea for black
and that's why after 97 the move knight
c7 is already a big mistake
so
white played bishop f4 this is a very
important move because it relieves the
knight it allows the knight to go to c7
without having to worry about guarding
the b4 square because now against bishop
b4 we can always react with bishop d2
so
black plays knight f6 another move
that's part of our original sketch
and of course
a move that basically forces
knight c7 and now after king d8
knight takes a8
so where do we go from here
again what are our options
you can take on e4
you can give the check on b4 you could
take the knight but it doesn't really
make that much sense to take the knight
when you could take on e4 with check
first and then just double back with the
queen right so so that's what black did
why not bishop before i mean it seems
like we can get this free developing
move in
what would be the problem with that
right it seems like after bishop d2
bishop takes queen takes
all you've really done
besides trading these these pieces is
get white's queen involved right
and this queen on d1 was much more
passive than it is now on d2
so
black
takes out the e4 pawn this is a very
important pawn to get rid of because if
we don't get rid of it
and white manages to somehow consolidate
this pawn center these central pawns
right this space advantage is going to
do what it does best right the key to
space to understanding what a space
advantage is good for
is
indivisible from
minor pieces right a space advantage is
only good for restricting minor pieces
right so
pawns on d4 and e4 are going to be a
nightmare for the knights on f6 and d7
especially but also the bishops are
going to have a hard time finding good
diagonals so we need to completely
destroy the center
after queen takes e4 knight e2
queen takes aa
this i would say is
in a way kind of the starting position
of the variation because both sides
ducked a few punches but
they were fairly easy
tactics right at least for two guys that
are
in the high 2700s
so this is where the game
begins because this is where the game
stops being forced right there are no
long forced sequences now it's all about
who has the better argument right
black is saying
okay
you know i'm down in exchange
but i have a pawn for it
this is perhaps one of the most common
material imbalances next to sacrificing
a pawn just being down upon the exchange
sacrifice
is a very
useful tool to create imbalances in a
position
so
black is going to say hey you know
it's not so much about the exchange i
have this three against one pawn
majority on the queen side you know i
have this potential for activating my
pieces i have a clear path for where i
want to put my pieces
meanwhile what's your plan is white what
are you going to do right
remember you never want to justify your
position in terms of your material
advantage
you never want to answer the question
why are you better because i have an
extra exchange because i have an extra
pawn that's not a good answer right you
want to say well because your king on d8
is vulnerable and i'm going to attack it
with this move that move and this move
or you know you have a weak pawn that i
can target with this move that move or
this one so
how is white going to play here what's
white's idea
[Music]
by the way i'm not sure i have the
answer to this question i was kind of
hoping you guys would help me find it
because aronian seems to have the answer
he won both games but actually i'm not
so convinced about the positions that he
got
the first thing i think of in this
position is trying to castle on the
king's side yeah and how would you do
that
because that because it certainly
doesn't seem like the easiest situation
for castling
i move my knight to
c3
yeah
and then
if the pawn attacks my knight
e4
no nevermind
but let's say black doesn't attack any
of your pieces let's say black is very
cooperative
and and whenever you create a threat he
just defends right maybe if knight c3
he'll go
queen b7 and a6 i don't know something
like that right i just want to let you
do what you want to do because i want
you to show me like what's your best
case scenario
probably c3 and then bishop e2
yes
that would be great right now there's
also some questions about whether your
g2 pawn might need protecting or not
maybe not
but that
that's priority number one for white get
this king out of the center right
because sometimes you don't need to
castle but here black has an open file
right that he wants to put a rook on
he's got the check on b4 you know he's
got knight coming to d5 you know you
really have no time to waste so
um
black white played queen d2
which i thought was a very strange move
because
it has nothing to do seemingly with
getting your king to safety
but
let's see it was that the move played in
both games no right later aronian would
play f3
but now
after queen d2
wait is that
oh no in the first game against
dominguez he played f3 actually which is
interesting because this move actually
does make sense
he's figuring okay
i'm blunting the queen's diagonal so
there's no pressure on g2 i'm
controlling the e4 square so maybe i can
go queen d2 without having to worry
about knight e4
and my next step is going to be maybe
knight c3 bishop e2 and castles right so
here
black played knight d5 which makes sense
bishop g5 check notice that
if we want to go knight c3 we have to do
something about this bishop
and
where do we put that bishop right if we
go to g3
now we have to worry about moves like
knight e3 it looked pretty scary
also we have to worry about bishop b4
and we don't have bishop d2 blocking the
check so we would have to go to f2 maybe
not the end of the world but okay also
not
ideal
so aronian decides to throw in this
check
to force f6 and then he brings the
bishop back to d2 so he covers e3 he
covers b4 and he's just trying to hold
down the fort so that he can go knight
c3 bishop e2 and castles
so
black plays bishop d6 bringing the
bishop out and making room for the rook
to come to e8
and after knight g3
we see that another
important point behind f3 is that it
provides support for the knight to come
to e4 now if rookie 8 which i think
no it wasn't played if rookie 8 we want
to be a little bit careful right because
after 94 what's going to happen
yeah just f5 right we lose the knight
and the game is over so after rookie
8 we want to be careful as black
not to make our opponent's
job easier than it has to be right when
we look at this position
we know
that white is trying to go bishop e2 and
castle king's side
so we want to look for options
that make this harder now when you look
at this purely from black's perspective
you're like oh i want a rook on e8 right
so i should just play rookie 8 check it
comes with tempo my position is better
than it was before but all you're really
doing
is helping white because white wants to
play bishop e2
so that's why
hikaru played the move queen v8 here now
i'm actually creating problems for you
i'm forcing you to make decisions if you
play your natural move bishop e2
black is going to take on g3
and after pawn takes
queen takes you have to go king f1 and
okay you've lost a second pawn now
i don't know if there's
some killer move here
probably not
how would you guys play as black
so in the chat they're
talking about the possibility of b4 but
you have to be careful right because
maybe i can go bishop take c4 and get
rid of that pawn
queen where e5
queen
where
did you say e5
yeah
well but there's a pawn there right yeah
so that's not going to work
now they're they're saying maybe h5 h4
and h3
now i'm wondering if that's
an actual threat because maybe when you
go h4 i can always go rook h3 or queen
e1 so what happens if i just take this
pawn
maybe not so much for the sake of the
pawn itself but i am activating my rook
considerably
and i might be
introducing some ideas of bishop a5
not entirely sure about this right so
h4
i like the the common in the just bring
the knight and bishop in somehow
i like the somehow part
um the somehow is really everything
so
are you really threatening anything with
h3 like if i just trade
maybe you are i don't know but let's say
i go queenie one
because now if you retreat the queen i
could take on h4 maybe
right and if you go queen b8 hitting my
rook
i don't know if this works but it might
be interesting right if we're
if we're talking about
using material as a bargaining chip
maybe i can give back the exchange
and now take this pawn
although i'm not
completely sold on this idea
there is a bishop check absolutely
right i could throw in this check
because if you go to the e file then i
have a discovery so you're probably
going to go knight b6
and then
i was wondering if after rook takes g7
this check was a problem but i don't
think so
i think i can just go king f2 yeah this
looks
like black's position is starting to
fall apart
so i think h5 is still a little bit
premature right you you still haven't
consolidated your position enough to
really
play a move that says you know this is a
one-sided game i can do whatever i want
well
what about this move
right if rook takes a7 is such a problem
why don't i just
consolidate my pawn chain
and uh prepare like they were saying
this this is the somehow right maybe i
can go knight b6
and bishop b7
and uh if my king gets into trouble it
can go to like c8 and b8 i can now
definitely consider something like h5 h4
h3
rookie 8 let's see what does
what does cypher say yeah like this is
absolutely fine for black right so so a6
um
isn't that a bit slow
what's wrong with slow
sometimes you got to take it slow right
what matters is that your opponent
doesn't have anything immediate that he
can do so if your opponent is uh is not
threatening anything
taking it slow
is a good strategy because it forces
your opponent to make a decision right
when you play the move a6
it's like you you're throwing the ball
back in your opponent's core and you're
like okay
you figure it out you know why why do i
have to do all the heavy lifting
so
i think
black's compensation is very interesting
here even if the queens were to come off
the board this three against one
guarantees
long-term compensation and usually
pretty good end games let's block that
so after queen c7
sorry queen b8
white played king f2
it's not quite the castling that we were
hoping for but at least white is trying
to
get the king out of dodge city
so
black
brought the rook to e8
and now after bishop e2
bishop c7 and i think this was a this
was a key moment
for black i'm not sure that bishop c7
was the right move i'm sure it wasn't a
terrible move or anything
but um
what are some of black's options here
right before we we commit to a move or
we even commit to analyzing a move
what are some of the moves that black
would like to play
so
can we attack the isolated pawn first
with the queen and then bring the knight
in
right so okay i think this is an
interesting move g6 because it seeks to
dominate the knight right white
might be trying to play knight f5 that
could be a problem so g6 is definitely a
good option
anything else
could be queen b6
all right putting some pressure on this
pawn i think that's what the idea of
bishop c7 was right that black wanted to
bring the bishop to b6 and attack the
pawn that way okay knight b6
that could be a move
i mean there's another move that you
always want to play which is a6 right a6
would just make sure that your
that your pawn chain never gets into
trouble and especially your a7 pawn
right that you never fall for something
like rook takes a7 or something like
that
so
this is where we're going to draw
this is our our sort of
well of ideas this is we're going to
take
where our variations are going to take
the raw materials from
so
i kind of like the move g6 i'm not
entirely sure
what white was going to do at the same
time what are some of the moves that
white wants to play right we have to we
can't just do this in a one-sided way we
have to see what does black want to do
what does white want to do and what's
sort of the
the intersection between those
okay rookie one has to be one of the
moves right so that then we can maybe go
bishop f1 maybe king g1
also a move that white might want to
play is knight e4
maybe another move could be bishop a5
so i think these are
you know a pretty good sampling
so i would say yeah probably rookie one
right because 94
maybe 94 is good i don't know
the knight certainly didn't seem to have
very good prospects on g3 and what
happens if black just says oh thanks for
the free pawn
g3
okay
and
is there a way to keep this variation
going to sort of keep black alive
because yeah if white plays rook takes
h2 it's over
yeah right we got a couple of options
here we got f5 we've got rook takes e4
because this knight needs to protect g3
so
uh rook takes e4 looks very interesting
especially if f takes e4
queen takes g3 king f1 it looks like
we're very close
um i wouldn't be surprised if something
like this worked
right and if you take either knight i'm
just checkmating you on h3 looks kind of
cool that both knights are hanging
so after rook takes e4 you probably have
to go rook takes h2
and now my rook is definitely hanging so
i would probably need to go rookie 7 to
protect here
what do you think of this position what
do you think is better here
who's made more progress over the past
two or three moves
[Music]
why do you say that
because
black has
not moved
the bishop and i am the seventh
file
so so black still hasn't really
activated these pieces which is a big
deal
so of all the things that black wanted
to do
he hasn't really done any of them
and of all the things that white wanted
to do has white accomplished any of them
yeah right okay i didn't castle but i
did activate my rook right my rook on h2
looks pretty good
without a dark square bishop this king
looks pretty safe
and if i want to i can play bishop f1
next i would say that white has a pretty
big advantage here and um
kind of
this is one of the one of the things i
like to do is just look at a position
sort of
give my my estimate of how it's going
and then compare it to the computer
right a lot of people what they do is
they'll go through the entire game with
the engine on
and i think that just atrophies your
brain like you're not really engaged
with the position you're just sort of
following what the computer says
so
um
oh look at this it's not that bad
i thought white would be at least plus
one here
so
maybe this g6 move let's see did we miss
anything
no 94 looks like the best move bishop
takes h through h2 not bad
g3 top choice boom rook takes e4 we're
good
right
oh now we know it's losing but rook
takes
rookie seven okay bishop a5
king e8 and b3 and apparently white does
retain
some initiative but nothing nothing too
terrible so the move g6
is a very interesting move
so we got one good candidate let's try
to look at another move so that we have
something to compare it to right because
maybe g6 is okay but maybe we have some
amazing move that we're that we're not
even considering
so
let's say i don't know let's say i play
a move like asics
right and uh
and white plays
rookie one
what can we do here
[Music]
like how how is black gonna do
some damage to white's position i mean
sure black could play like knight b6
bishop b7 and uh and play that
game as if nothing had happened and i
not i don't even think that would be a
bad thing necessarily
but is there a way for black to really
sink his teeth into white's position
so here there's a suggestion for bishop
f4
but i don't know if that's really a good
trade for us i mean in the previous
variation i was kind of missing my dark
square bishop as black
i mean if you go
oh trading on g3 i definitely don't like
this
because i think that just relieves a lot
of the pressure
i'm gonna go bishop f1 next bishop a5
and it looks like all of my pieces are
finding good squares as white right so
white white is solving the problem
white's position looks a little bit
uh
cumbersome like the pieces are stepping
on each other's toes if white can sort
of
get a decent square for each piece then
white is going to be better
so i don't like this idea at all bishop
f4
doesn't look as bad
but i also don't really see
you solving your problems right if i
just go bishop f1 it doesn't seem like
we're we're interfering with what white
is trying to do
so white wants to go bishop f1 maybe
king g1
maybe not king g1 the king looks pretty
good on f2
let's see knight f4 so if i go bishop f1
again it doesn't seem like we're
interfering right in any any meaningful
way bishop a5 queen d2 is coming i can
take on e8 maybe bring the other rook to
e1 i can start looking at knight f5 94
there's a nice flow to white's position
so
when we start to see that our opponent
has
this kind of flow
we have to disrupt it somehow we have to
create a threat
for kind of an existential problem to
that setup
and then
then i could
maybe move like
that's really good now bishop c7 is
always interesting and it's very similar
to what dominguez played in the game
especially because it also introduces
the idea
of attacking d4 right this pawn on d4
is a liability for white but you can't
really feel it because there's no easy
way for black to attack it but now
the the pawn is on a6 you could also
consider a move like queen a7
because now if you continue doing what
you want to do i can take on d4 with
check
and
you have to be very careful here
so
after queen a7 i would think that you
would have to start with bishop a5 check
and only then bishop f1
but i don't know about this
right because now i i can go bishop c7
so i wouldn't want to waste a move on
bishop c7
you know to prevent bishop a5 i would
rather just meet bishop a5 with bishop
c7
and
here i don't know if bishop takes i
think king takes my king is pretty happy
here looks fairly safe
and if bishop f1
now after rook takes you can't go queen
takes because
you're almost getting mated here
so you would have to go king takes and
your strategy is not working right you
wanted to tuck your king away maybe on
f2 or g1 and now it's being dragged
back into the center so let's see
what do you guys think of this position
where does it
fall like in terms of better for white
better for black how does it compare to
the g6 line that we just looked at
because ultimately our goal
is to have at least two options that we
can choose from right a point of
reference and then a move that we can
determine whether it's better or worse
so that's how usually we want to make
our decisions during a chess game it's
kind of like an informed decision
feels better
so let's see the other one i think was
like
0.5 for white
this is 0.6 so it's about the same maybe
a little bit worse so
uh
let's see
does the computer say it says g6 is good
it says knight seven to b6
is even better oh sorry so in this
position
oh it says a6 is good
and after rookie one instead of queen a7
knight b6
and after
bishop f1
it says
queen rook takes queen takes
oh this is funny and f5 right so playing
against this knight so that it can't go
to e4 or f5
and if we keep
going with our strategy
what does it say
oh it just keeps building up the
position queen c7
and if you do something like bishop a5
then maybe just
it says queen e7 i would be very tempted
to do something like g6 and now your
knight is dead
so
it's already starting to say that black
might
be the one pressing for the advantage
so let's see
what happened in the game
black played bishop c7 which looks
like it's definitely part of black's
plan so it's it's a move that's not
wrong
rook e1
bishop b6
and king g1
interesting
so
white cuts his losses and says okay you
know you want this pawn so bad you can
have it
and now black plays knight e5 so what's
going on why can't i just
say thank you for the pawn
i'm guessing why of course it's going to
go king h1
so white doesn't have to worry about the
king anymore that's the good news that's
sort of what you're getting for your
money
and now what what do we make of this
we've got two pawns for the exchange now
bishop f2
okay
how do you feel about this position
that's black yeah
over the past couple of moves
who do you feel has has gotten closer to
what they want
i still think white
why do you think that
because they can still play
a5
um
and
the knight
on
d7 and the bishop on c8 still open
that's black
okay and how has winning the d4 pawn
sort of affected
our
our sketch of the position
because we need to be very careful not
to get
swayed by the nominal value of pieces
right like when we're first taught the
rules of chess we're taught oh the pawn
is worth one so you see a pawn you take
it you're like yeah i got one more
right but
but as you start to get better
you begin to see pieces for the relative
value like what they're actually doing
in a position
this pawn on d4
isn't really doing anything for white in
fact it's getting in the way of white's
pieces so so white is
is happy to give you this pawn because
he's getting a lot in return right after
bishop takes d4 king h1 first of all
my king is safe
secondly
you just helped me open up the d file
and
i mean look at all the stuff that you
have on the d file this is bound to
result in some kind of problem for black
i'm threatening bishop a5 if you go
bishop f2 i would already start looking
at what happens if bishop a5 because
your knight is hanging and if you go
knight b6
i can still take it because this knight
is pinned
so
the thing that i
wasn't so crazy about
in terms of this bishop c7 bishop b6
idea is that i don't think this is a
pawn you really want as black i think
that pawn
is like one of black's best pieces you
know it's it's the it's the best
defender of your king it's preventing
white's queen from absolutely pummeling
pummeling you on the d file
so that's why i i kind of like what the
computer was doing back here
right where it was saying what was it
like a6
uh i forget
yeah like a6 uh rookie one
and now it was saying like just knife b6
you know f5 g6
queen c7 queen e7
you know for for a chess engine to not
even pay attention to a pawn you have to
give it some credit you know you have to
say okay maybe that pawn is really not
that important
so
uh
let's see what happened in the game
right here
king
and now knight e5
king h1
and knight c6 so black says okay you
know you got your king to h1 but at
least
i was able to rearrange my pieces in
such a way that they look more active
than they were before maybe this wasn't
the original arrangement that we foresaw
right we were looking at the knight on
b6 and the bishop on d6 but maybe this
is a valid approach as well
so
now that white took care of his highest
priority which was getting that king out
of e1 can turn his attention
to creating some actual problems for
black right it's a lot harder to create
problems when you have problems of your
own so now white is trying to blow up
the position right
if
c takes b3
well i could consider bishop takes b5
but also queen takes b3 hitting the
knight first looks very tempting
as the position keeps opening up
things start looking less convincing for
black right so i think that the game is
already starting to take a turn for the
worst
when the knight was on e5
oh because the pawn is pinned right
there's a bishop on b6
yeah
so after knight c6 uh b3
c3 i think this is really the the only
logical way for black to play to try to
keep as many files closed as possible
because that means that the rooks won't
really be able to count for much right
rooks need open files to really thrive
and right now there's only one
and
that's one too many already for black
so
now after bishop takes b5
the point is if you take the bishop
right you can't take the knight right
away because you're just going to lose
your queen after d takes you on and your
rook
but you can
take on e8 first with check and after
king takes you take on c6 again with
check and you take on d2 or maybe you
just take on d5 first and the game is
over
so
after bishop takes b5 it looks like
black's position is about to collapse
right bishop d7
rook takes bishop takes
and now simply bishop e1
so at this point
black is still down in exchange not that
that that's a big deal i mean that was
an assumed risk in the beginning
but
black no longer has the three against
one pawn majority on the queen side that
is a big deal right because that's one
of the good things that we could have
said about our position that we have
this long term advantage on the queen
side
white doesn't have an exposed king in
the center
black does okay but there's still a pawn
on d4 that's the good news and i have a
pawn on
c3 but i think having lost
that three against one is a real problem
moreover
i think
if we if we had to sketch out white's
position white's gonna go bishop f2
knight e4 maybe knight c5 maybe queen d3
targeting
uh h7 maybe queen e2 followed by rookie
one and getting some play along the e
file
whereas it's very hard to propose an
active plan for black
as black you're you're just doing
patchwork here you're just trying to
prevent the position from collapsing so
i would say that black is probably
already losing here yeah this is like
plus four for white
so where was where was the big big
blunder uh
it might have just been this
rearrangement of pieces right the bishop
c7 thing so
here bishop b6 king g1 95 yet
and then the position just
unraveled
so anyway
aronian won that game it was a nice game
and it then
just a few days later he gets the same
line against hikaru nakamura
and he improves upon it as white which
means that he didn't like the position
that he got his white otherwise he would
have just played the same way
so now instead of f3 he plays queen d2
now this
must be a deep move because
it's ignoring the main problem that he
actually successfully solved in the
first game
so now after knight d5
knight c3 so his idea is i don't i don't
want to do this thing with my bishop i
don't want to go back and forth i don't
want to put my bishop on a passive
square you want that bishop you can have
it
so bishop b4
black wants to keep this knight on d5
oops
and now bishop e2 so notice this is kind
of a cleaner solution for white right
white doesn't have to go f3 king f2 and
make all those strange contortions
he's just getting the knight out the
bishop out and he's going to castle and
that's it
so now
rookie 8
and
white plays bishop g3 what happens if
white just does what he wants to do the
castle king side
on c3 and somehow you're gonna hang that
bishop on e2 yep
again the somehow is always
everything right so
black still creates a problem right
black still doesn't let you get to where
you want to go so that's why he goes
bishop g3 so now
you can't unload your knight on f4 and
i'm ready to castle right so it looks
like white is very very close to getting
a much better version of what he got in
the previous game
so
black plays knight f6
again the question what happens if
castle's king sight
how would you do it uh i would go
bishop takes
knight on c3
take back upon
well i can't really do it that's a
that's a very strong statement
i
i could totally do it it would just cost
me a pawn but in a game where we're just
throwing material around like it's
nothing right upon i'm just
yeah what is a pawn to me
and the
important thing is like what am i
getting for that pawn
right have i solved my problems as white
no
what was my main concern is white
castle
how does my king look
looks amazing right i haven't seen a
safer king in my life
so yeah i mean this is a complete i
would say this is completely winning for
white i've got moves like d5 i've got
moves like queen a5 i've got moves like
rookie one
i've got opposite color bishops which
means whoever starts attacking first is
basically gonna win the game
i would say this this has to be in the
neighborhood like plus four plus five
again let's see oh plus seven yeah
so
so the the material really means nothing
here what matters
at least if you look at it from black's
perspective is being able to hold this
position together if black can keep this
as is right if black can consolidate
this position you know maybe go like a6
um somehow reincorporate this queen into
the game also you know increase the
pressure on c3 maybe with something like
knight e4 but black needs
to do something because this king is no
longer a target so we need to find
something else
to put pressure on to create a problem
for white to solve
otherwise white's game is going to get
very easy right white's just going to go
rookie 1 bishop f3 and the game is over
right so here
icaru played 94.
so
white's getting hit pretty hard on c3
the idea is not to win upon the idea is
just to overwhelm white with our active
pieces so now after queen c2
bishop f5 so the pieces just keep flying
out
now i don't know about bishop f5 here
i mean what is this the only move i mean
what other moves could we could we play
can we still do a6 what happens if
knight takes b5
so here bishop takes oops sorry
and if pawn takes
because if we take the pawn i think
white's idea is to go bishop f3 and
these bishops are looking pretty nice
you know also there's a queen takes h7
possibly
um i would say that what there's also
rookie one i would say let's see yeah
plus three for white so
that's winning
so we need to do something that will
interfere with white's plan of just
going bishop f3 and rookie one and i
think that was that was the point of
bishop f5 because
well white played bishop h4 if you go
bishop f3 what's going to happen
yeah knight takes g3 right discovery on
the queen i'm gonna win an entire rook
here
maybe
i should you know take on c3 first just
to prevent any kind of bishop takes d5
so something like this would probably be
best because if you take here in between
move i'm just going to take
and you don't have enough time to take
on c3
but i was thinking what happens
if i do something
like takes
takes and bishop takes
right you can't really i don't think you
can really play bishop f3 yet because
i'm going to take the rook
and if you move the rook
which is unclear where you're going to
move it to but let's say i don't know
something like rook d1 maybe
now you have bishop f3 coming
but maybe i can hold that
maybe i can do something like
i don't know like
bishop b7 or maybe bishop e6
and if you go bishop f3 what i can say
is okay
you castled your king your king is safe
your bishops look fantastic
but now instead of three against one on
the queen side i have three against zero
right so
who's going to stop me now
so you you have a counter-balancing
force right you need to create something
like that so let's see
if we're anywhere in the ballpark here
right so
if knight takes pawn takes bishop takes
i was saying
rook d1
oh look it says g6 absolutely
inconceivable move oh it wants to go
bishop f5 right so bishop f3
i guess bishop f5 doesn't work because
of takes
but even this is crazy look at this so
it takes takes
i'm down a piece but
it's barely better
for white
so it says that it's better to take with
the other knight this is curious and
after pawn
bishop takes
and rook b1 and now
just bam queen d5 and bishop f3 bishop
b7
so
yeah it looks like black's position is
dominant despite white getting the safe
king and the active bishops i have the
three against zero the knight is stable
i've got this nice battery centralized
my queen
and
yeah it looks like
if white's not careful why it's going to
be worse
so
very difficult position
after queen c2
black played bishop f5 maybe i don't
know maybe this move was missed bishop
h4 because now after f6 i can go bishop
f3 and there's no knight takes g3
and now after bishop takes b takes
g5
it looks like oh now you just go bishop
g3 and knight takes g3 and you lose
so
what is a what is white going to do here
yes so here in the chat they they found
or remembered the right move at first
white threw in rookie one so that if you
go pawn takes bishop takes i'm just
trading off a bunch of pieces and your
king's gonna be in trouble
so black played knight f4 bringing the
queen into things
and now queen a2 and the point is
that
white has identified the lifeblood of
black's position it's the pawn majority
on the queen side so
now if something like g takes h4
after queen takes a7
your position is nearly collapsing
i'm threatening rook a8 rook takes and
then to take on e4
and this tension is just killing you and
you don't have the three against one
so black played queen b7 and now after
queen takes it's kind of similar
except there's no rook a8 to worry about
that you didn't take the bishop
right so now after takes takes
f3
uh rookie two i guess if you just take
bishop takes and you're just down in
exchange for nothing basically right
because two against one is not nearly
good enough
so after rookie two bishop f2 b4 takes c
c3 takes takes
king h1 and this pawn is easily stopped
right because
these two minor pieces against rook and
what
two pawns rooking two pawns against two
minor pieces is usually kind of a
winning advantage
unless you know there's like some very
specific
exception
but here
basically white's going to do whatever
he wants
so just going to wipe out all the pawns
and i think he must have resigned pretty
soon
this looks pretty hopeless
so f5 is coming for h7
yeah
okay and he resigned anyway i thought
these two games were really interesting
even though white won both games you
might say oh this line is just bad but
the struggle was very interesting and
black was always so close to making it
work but of course you know if if you
see two guys like dominguez and nakamura
lose it means that this must be a
difficult position to play in any case
uh thanks for coming out thanks for
watching i hope you enjoyed it and i'll
see you guys next time